on prime crime
i survived
i survived that man and i'm here and i'm
able to look at him amber
snuck in the she
reached got the
round house in a clash of celebrities
that had everyone asking who's telling
the truth
you got this going
for real because god did he just hit me
no
there's a need for conflict
see what the jury and judge think tell
the world johnny
[Music]
hi there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to a very special prime crime
now we usually cover the most
fascinating criminal cases but we're
doing something a little bit different
we're standing right now outside of the
fairfax county courthouse in fairfax
county virginia this was the site of one
of the most watched talked-about debated
and high-profile trials that we have
ever covered this was the case that
brought hollywood into the courtroom
can you please tell the jury why you're
here today
um
yes
that's acclaimed actor johnny depp no
he's not playing a part in a legal drama
rather he's testifying in real life
about some very serious allegations
ms hurd
brought these disturbing criminal
acts
that were not based in
any species of truth
in 2022 johnny depp went to trial after
suing his ex-wife actress amber hurd for
50 million dollars claiming defamation
he argued that she lied about him in a
2018 washington post op-ed piece that
implied he abused her during the course
of their relationship there are three
statements that we respectfully ask each
of you to focus on
but never
did i myself
reach the point of uh
striking
miss heard in any way
he says her false accusations cost him
his career and reputation it's very
strange when
one day your
[Music]
cinderella so to speak and then in 0.6
seconds your
quasimodo i didn't
deserve that nor did my
children nor did the people who have
believed in me for
all these years
but according to amber heard johnny depp
wasn't telling the truth
because he's guilty
he's he knows he's lying
otherwise why can't he look at me
i survived
i survived that man and i'm here and i'm
able to look at him
and not only that she countersued depp
for 100 million dollars heard claim that
depp's attorney adam waldman who was
acting on behalf of the pirates star
published a series of statements in the
media that defamed her namely calling
her allegations a hoax and the aftermath
of these alleged attacks staged
adam waldman depp's lawyer said
afterwards amber heard and her friends
in the media use fake sexual violence
allegations is both a sword and a shield
depending on their needs is this a true
or false statement
false
the johnny depp amber trial was an event
unlike anything else
[Applause]
attended by supporters of deaf and heard
it was a cultural milestone people
waiting hours in line to get into court
fans cheering depp each day i think it
shows that men can speak up too i
believe her i don't think it's a hoax
costumes signs messages the social media
activity and interest in this trial
reached unprecedented levels how exactly
did johnny depp and amber heard end up
in a courtroom let's start from the
beginning the two actors met while
making the 2011 film the rum diary and
everything changed during one scene
when would you say your romantic
relationship with miss heart actually
began
i think there was something in the kiss
in the shower
that was very
real it didn't feel like a normal scene
anymore it felt uh it felt more real mr
had come to my trailer
we
had a glass of wine and
we kissed
then we fell in love
that seems to be the only part they
actually agree upon because what
happened next between the two formed the
basis for the lawsuit
according to heard and those close to
her drugs and alcohol caused depth to
become a monster it would be a blow up
and
at first it was just to throw something
smash some things
threw a glass at me and shattered behind
me and i remember thinking that it like
very easily could have hit me you know
he was almost unrecognizable when he was
drinking and using to an excess and he
would just say
really horrible
horrible horrible things about her or to
her
he called her a fucking used up trash
bag uh
slimy whore
saggy whore then the door
like burst open and johnny came
charging in looked intoxicated
kind of stumbling and
screamed get your bitch out of here as
he
ran in my direction
do you remember the first time that he
physically hit you yes i asked him about
the tattoo he has on his arm he
um said it says wino
says why not and i laughed and
slapped me across the face
he said you think it's so funny you
think it's funny bitch you think you're
a funny bitch
and he slapped me again god did he just
hit me
no i knew it was
wrong and i knew that i had to leave him
and that's what broke my heart
because i didn't believe him
heard would testify to multiple
instances of alleged physical emotional
mental and verbal abuse a narrative
supported by text messages from depp
you text mr betany let's burn amber your
display of guilt and matronlyness as a
lesbian camp counselor was plenty
you agree that referring to amber as a
lesbian camp counselor is a highly
offensive
reference to make
i don't think i'm the first to say that
including messages where it implied he
apologized for abusive behavior
of course i am sorry
i really don't know why or what happened
but i will never do it again
audio tapes capturing revealing moments
between the couple
but put your fucking cigarette down on
someone else you fuck consequences of
your actions that's it shut up and then
there was the infamous kitchen video a
tape secretly recorded by herd of depp
one morning in his la
[Music]
what
home
[Music]
yeah you're right i just woke up and you
were so sweet and nice
[Music]
we're not even fighting this morning all
i did was say sorry did something happen
to you
this morning
i don't think so
no that's something you want to see
crazy
oh you're crazy
are you crazy have you drunk this whole
thing this
morning you got this guy
you got this going
oh really
really
didn't it you were smashing
you were violent in that clip correct
um
clearly i was having a bad
time
i thought what was most interesting is
that she
tried to hide it from me and then that
she
laughed
and smiled at the end
i i did assault um
a couple of cabins but i did not touch
miss hurt you poured yourself a
um a mega pint of red wine correct
a mega pint
through this evidence and herd's
multiple accounts of depp attacking her
she attempted to show that she wasn't
lying about the a-list star
the question was was this the full story
and there's no injuries to your face in
this picture are there
not that
this picture shows
so there's no medical records reflecting
any injuries to your face after hit he
hit you several times i did not need to
go to the doctor at the time
they always say there are three sides to
the story what each side says and then
the truth for now here's depp's version
of the breakdown in the relationship and
as you'll hear it was a lot different
than herds
when did miss herd's behavior towards
you begin to change
i think things first thing started
coming up and it was
[Music]
i was suddenly just wrong
about everything
there were several occasions where
miss heard would
tell me what a bad father i was
and that i
had no idea how to parent
it's to slice you up it's to bring you
down it's to demean you
have you witnessed any occasions on
which
ms hurd wasn't nice to your brother i i
have actually
she called him an old fat man
no one does jump 21 drunk straight when
they're in their 20s no you're right
that's not going out blind you're a jill
joke did you have an opportunity to
observe how the relationship evolved
i did
to
they started to argue and
it was always taking place because you
know misheard would start this argument
doc i don't need you i don't want
anything you're the biggest
fake
[Laughter]
depp testified that not only was he not
the aggressor in their disputes but that
heard was the actual abuser and him the
victim she would uh
strike out she would
it could begin with a slap it could
begin with a
shove
it could begin with you know throwing a
tv remote at my head
which is a need for conflict the only
thing i learned to do with it is exactly
what i did as a child
by the way you i'm sorry that i didn't
uh uh hit you
across the face in a proper slap but i
was hitting you it was not punching you
babe you're not punched i'm sorry i hit
you like this but i did not punch you i
did not
deck you i
was hitting you
you are such a baby girl the fuck up
johnny physical fights
i did start a physical fight you did so
because
yes you did so you did the right thing
the big thing the you know what you are
admirable
when we return we show both versions of
various events to determine what's
really going on
they engaged in what i saw as mutual
abuse
because the next move if i don't walk
away
it's gonna be a bug bath
in 2022 actor johnny depp was embroiled
in a lawsuit with his ex-wife actress
amber hurd he accused her of defamation
by alleging she falsely implied he was a
domestic abuser in a 2018 washington
post op-ed piece
heard responded by counter-suing depp
saying he and his attorney coordinated a
smear campaign in the media calling her
account a hoax
the question was who to believe
and he balled up his fists
leaned back
and head butted me squaring the nose
instantly
searing pain heard explained that many
times she had to cover up her injuries
with makeup a reason why numerous
witnesses testified they never saw
bruises
for example her former makeup artist
testified what she had to do to conceal
bruises unheard before an appearance on
the james corden show
she had injuries
it could have looked like somebody had
headbutted her lightly so she had a
discoloration here under both eyes and
on the bridge of the and the bridge of
the nose
recovered
you know the
discoloration the bruises
with a little slightly heavier concealer
remember clearly talking that we had no
other option that night but then to use
a red blood like a really red lipstick
to
you know make sure we could cover up
the injuries on the lip heard claimed
that not only did depp beat her up and
also verbally emotionally and
psychologically abuse her but that he
also
sexually assaulted her he's like
grabbing my my my breasts he's touching
my thighs
and he rips my underwear off
proceeds to do a cavity search
have you ever sexually assaulted miss
heard
never
depp said heard was the one who attacked
him
and she
squared off at me
and i said go ahead
hit me
in order to make sense of this he said
she said case let's go to both sides of
some key events australia 2015. while
depp was filming pirates of the
caribbean five he and heard got into a
major fight at his home with him losing
the top of his finger
how exactly that happened though is in
dispute
she threw the large bottle
and it
made contact
and shattered
uh
everywhere
i was
looking directly at
my bones
was the vodka bottle intact
no
there was a large chunk of a bottle
which i guess was the rest of that
and several other i mean lots of other
broken glass around the area house
manager ben king also testified what
heard told him after ben have you ever
been so angry with someone you just lost
it with them
curiously though depp didn't originally
tell people what happened i said that i
had uh smashed it
in
in these large accordion doors
why would you lie about that i didn't
want to
get her in trouble even medical
professionals couldn't agree on the
exact cause of the injury
so this is a
mechanism of injury that has high
velocity or force generally a crush type
injury could this injury have been
sustained in the manner mr depp
described
i do believe so did mr depp's finger
injury happen as a result of a vodka
bottle being thrown at him no
no no significant injury to the dorset
with the finger and with that
type of a crush injury we would
anticipate both injury to the fingernail
and other parts of the finger
amber heard has a completely different
explanation an explanation that we warn
you is graphic and disturbing
not only does she not admit to throwing
a bottle of depth she claims depp
actually injured his finger from
attacking her and sexually assaulting
her he picks up the phone and starts
bashing the phone against the wall with
the next thing i remember
i always been over um
backwards
on the bar i felt this pressure
it didn't feel pain it was just a
pressure on my
pubic bone and i just remember
thinking please god please
thanks
i hope it's not broken
but is heard telling the truth let's
listen to some opposing testimony and
evidence
did you observe any damaged phones
no
and how did miss heard seem to you when
you saw her uh on that day when you
arrived to extract him
crazy
crazy
crazy
fierce
yeah
that's what what i recall hearing is as
i'm getting johnny out yeah just call
for your guys covered like you always do
in australia when we had the big fight
where i lost the tip of my finger
at least
five bathrooms and two bedrooms i went
to
you don't escape the fight you escape
the solution we cannot work it out if
you run away to the bathroom every time
so he penetrates you with this bottle
but you don't know how he got the bottle
right that is correct
and he did that right after he lost the
tip of his right middle finger again i
don't remember the exact sequence moving
on a few months later amber heard says
depp got into a physical altercation
with her sister whitney he threw
the
red bull can up at
me bolted up the steps
i don't know how he
managed to get his hands in my hair so
fast yanking me down and
hit me in the face with this cast my
sister
all of a sudden put herself
in between johnny and i her back was to
the staircase in my head instantly think
of
kate moss in the stairs
and i
swung at him he comes up behind me
strikes me in the back kind of just
somewhere over here he strikes me in the
back i hear amber shout don't hit my
sister
she smacks him lands one johnny had
already grabbed amber by the hair with
one hand and was whacking her repeatedly
in the face with the other
but depp's account once again is a lot
different
mr depp could you please explain to the
jury the circumstances that led to you
having um the bruise that's reflected in
this photograph she was
coming out you know
trying to
uh
well trying to get to me whitney stepped
in front of amber
and was facing amber
to stop amber
and
and
when she was in between us
amber
snuck in the she
reached got the
round house in i saw miss heard throw a
red bull can
that struck mr depp in the back
at one point she spit
at him
mr death
went upstairs
and
rearranged her closet for her um
threw down
probably every rack of clothing i heard
and saw a
closed fist um contact
mr depp and the left side of his face in
your time working for mr depp have you
ever seen mr deb physically abuse ms
hurd
i have not
and that reference to kate moss while
the supermodel herself cleared that up
did mr depp push you in any way down the
stairs
no he never pushed me kicked me
or
threw me down any stairs
then there's may 21 2016 an event that
caused her to seek out a restraining
order against depp which ultimately led
to the demise of the marriage
however before getting into the details
of the alleged attack we have to address
what fueled the fight
according to depp before heard left for
coachella his team informed him of
something that was left for him in his
bed
what was the photograph of mr depp
on
my side of the bed
um
was human fecal matter and did you have
any discussions with miss heard on the
way to coach hello that evening
we had a conversation pertaining to the
surprise she left in the boss's bed and
what did miss heard say about the
defecation in mr duff's bed
a horrible practical jerk gone wrong
first of all i don't think that's funny
i don't know what
a grown woman
does that's disgusting
fast forward to may 21 2016.
what do you recall
with respect to
a telephone call you received from amber
she put me on speakerphone
so i was talking to both of them johnny
thinks that
you and i together
defecated on his pillow
and so he got very agitated by the fact
that she and i thought it was funny he
came clomping back down the stairs i
heard like a
noise and then the phone dropped
she said to her
oh
you think i hit you
you think i can hit you
what if i peel your
hair back
and then i heard the phone drop again
and then i heard her scream
i hung up with her and immediately
called 9-1-1
with that pixel just pulls his arm back
with the foam and throws it at my face
hit me
right in my it felt like my eye
i put my
head in my hands
and
immediately start crying
she was calling for help and that had
never happened before
and i went up to him
and he was yelling and yelling
and then at that point
jerry and sean came in
from the front door
of ph3 and came in and they you know
they were like boss boss you know come
on let's get out of here
they finally left
this is amber's face
it's red
does this
um fairly inaccurately depict
this herd's condition that you observed
that evening
yes this is amber's face turned at a
slight profile
her eye is red and bruised
yet when police arrived to the penthouse
listen to what they observed or rather
didn't observe did you
notice any injuries on this herd
i did not
would you agree it's a red mark on her
face
from what i saw was red from her crying
there was no red marks from
any other thing it was consistent with
her crying
uh miss heard
refused any medical treatment and had no
visible injuries there was no sign of
struggle
and
the victim or correction the witness
that was there that i spoke with
was uncooperative as well
i did not want to speak to them
i wanted to protect johnny
i didn't want him to be arrested
i didn't want him to be in trouble i
didn't want the world to know
not only did officers not see any
injuries but neither did several
witnesses in the days afterwards i say
to amber as i'm walking up he hit you
and she goes yeah he threw a phone at me
and hit me get out she puts her face out
like that i'm looking at her forehead
i'm looking at the side of a side of a
rye i'm looking at a cheek i'm looking
at her chin i'm looking at the other
side of the face i'm looking at the
whole thing
and i don't see
anything
that's correct i didn't see any muscle
bruises
you didn't see any swelling either did
you mr romero
that's correct
no swallowing she was only
and she was only three or four feet away
from you correct
all
right depp asserts that herd manufacture
these bruises
coming up the story takes a wild turn
having a photo shoot inside the
courthouse while you were getting a dvro
i would not characterize it that way
miss vasquez
you have a mark on your face right
mister
yes
didn't use your bruise kit this time to
cover it up no i was the only day i
actually walked out of my house without
makeup on
i don't know how to get my um
the abuse and the abuse thing is is
we've got to deal with that yeah
[Music]
when johnny depp sued his ex-wife amber
heard for defamation after she penned a
2018 washington post op-ed piece that
implied he was a domestic abuser the
central issue was whether or not she was
making this up
heard countersued depp for statements
his attorney made claiming her abuse
allegations were a hoax and she strongly
defended herself
ms vasquez has suggested that you faked
bruises on your face is that true
absolutely not i didn't need to
in determining whether heard was the
type of person who would falsely accuse
someone of physical and sexual violence
heard's mental health ended up becoming
a key factor in this case
heard's expert forensic psychologist dr
dawn hughes testified that heard showed
clear signs of ptsd and of being a
victim misheard's report of intimate
partner violence
and the records that i reviewed is
consistent with what we know in the
field about intimate partner violence
characterized by physical violence
psychological aggression
sexual violence coercive control
and surveillance behavior i don't
care you shut up with that
this is not happening
[Music]
in fact heard presented the testimony of
actress ellen barkin who helped to
corroborate the abuse allegations by
testifying about her own experiences
with the actor
he was drunk all the time most a lot of
the time
mr depp threw a wine bottle across the
room the hotel room on one instance he's
just a jealous man controlling where are
you going who are you going with
however depp's expert dr shannon curry
provided a completely different
diagnosis a diagnosis that was quite
troubling
misheard did not have ptsd
and there were also
pretty significant indications that she
was grossly exaggerating symptoms of
ptsd the results of ms heard's
evaluation supported two diagnoses
borderline personality disorder and
histrionic personality disorder
like i said there's instability and
emotions borderline personality disorder
you're having these fluctuating moods
constantly and again this
hypersensitivity
to being slighted they'll make a lot of
accusations they will often physically
prevent their partner from trying to
leave if their partner wants to get
space from all of this intense emotion
and oftentimes they will
be abusive to their partners a boxer
can't go 12 rounds without a minute
break i'm not not giving you a minute
break you do it at minute three at the
beginning of an argument i fucking go to
the into the bathroom and sit on the
floor bam bam bam here you come
okay so let me go and you go and i'll
speak to you in a couple hours
okay
may i go away it causes me so much
stress when you leave when you walk away
from me with that it's like you're you
don't understand how much worse you're
making this they'll make threats using
the
legal system so
they might say that they are going to
file a restraining order or claim abuse
or they might do these things to
essentially try to keep their partner
from leaving this brings us to may 2016.
in the days after heard alleged depth
threw a cell phone at her face heard
filed for divorce and obtained a
domestic violence restraining order
against depp while the actor was out of
town at the time it felt like the
hardest thing i've ever had to do
and why did you file for divorce
i knew if i did not likely not literally
survive
when heard went to the court to get the
order though tmz was mysteriously
alerted
their objective was to capture her
leaving the courthouse
and then
she was going to sort of stop and turn
towards the camera to display the bruise
on the right side of her face deal edge
bruce
did your team of videographers get the
shot of amber heard we did
they had alerted tmz that you would be
filing a tro against mr depp that very
day didn't you no i did one day you
didn't bother to wear makeup to cover up
the mark on your face i did not call tmz
or any other news source
also before heard scheduled divorce
deposition tmz received a leaked copy of
the video of depp's violent behavior in
his home
yes the video was sent in through our
email tip line and included a link
from
some unknown
dropbox type
website but you testified that you had
absolutely nothing to do with the
video's release right absolutely not
you heard mr tumain testify that the
cabinet video was posted
15 minutes after tmz received it yes
that's what i heard him say and that
this could only have been possible if
the video was received directly from the
source yes i heard him say that i don't
know if that's true or if that's
possible
you edited that video before you gave it
to tmz so that only mr depp would look
bad yes that's absurd
depp's theory was that heard never
really was the victim or was in danger
but instead she orchestrated an
elaborate abuse plot in order to receive
a favorable divorce settlement
one problem for depp is what he ended up
signing in the divorce agreement if it
contains the statement neither party has
made false accusations for financial
gain
neither party has made false accusations
for financial gain did i read that right
you did mr robin take that down michelle
in the aftermath of the couple's divorce
depp ended up paying heard seven million
dollars a settlement amount that hurd
had pledged to donate the entirety of to
charities but that didn't quite happen
had any payments been made
by this herd
to the children's hospital
in connection with the
the 3.5 million dollar pledge
250 000
so after
this december 2018
donation has ms heard made any
donations directly or indirectly to the
aclu
no we
learned that she was having financial
difficulties
so in this october 2018 interview you
said that you had quote donated
end quote your entire divorce settlement
to charity right that's correct as of
today
you have not donated
paid
seven million dollars of your divorce
settlement to charity right
i have not been able to fulfill those
those uh obligations yet
and that's because you did want
something you wanted mr duff's money
didn't get it wasn't interested in it
and speaking of the aclu we learned the
organization was instrumental in
actually working with herd in drafting
and pitching the op-ed at the center of
this lawsuit depp cast doubt on the
credibility of the piece by highlighting
that it coincided with the release of
heard's movie aquaman
were you trying to boost your sales for
aquaman since it was coming out in that
same time frame a major emotion picture
or major franchise like that is not
aided by the publication of a
an op-ed in the washington post after
depp sued herd for the op-ed his lawyer
adam waldman issued several statements
to the daily mail one statement called
heard sexual violence claims fake
another alleged that heard and her
friends staged the may 21 2016 scene to
seemingly frame depth for physical abuse
another called herds abuse allegations a
hoax these statements form the basis for
herd's counter claims against depp aside
from the legal question of whether they
were defamatory the other legal issue
became was waldman acting on behalf of
depp
when is the first time that you saw this
statement by mr waldman
august 2020 when i was countersued by
misheard
so did you in fact have a meeting with
the mail online on 17 february
i see this and it wouldn't surprise me
if we had
and was mr depp with you when you had
the meeting
i believe mr depp was with me when we
had this meeting
you and mr waldman together met with the
daily mail in london in february 2020
didn't you
i just don't i don't recall it okay you
don't disagree with mr waldman's
testimony that you and he met with
people from the daily mail in london in
february 2020 correct
if that's mr waldman's testimony then
but i just didn't necessarily know who
these people were right
coming up the dramatic conclusion to the
depp heard saga
[Music]
we have big breaking news here in
fairfax virginia the jury has reached a
verdict
[Music]
what have you lost as a result of
misheard making these allegations
against you
nothing less than everything
johnny depp filed a 50 million dollar
lawsuit against his ex-wife amber heard
for defamation claiming that she lied
about him being a domestic abuser in a
2018 washington post op-ed piece heard
responded by counter-suing depp for 100
million dollars arguing depp defamed her
when his attorney adam waldman issued a
series of false statements to the daily
mail calling her abuse allegations a
hoax and fake the seven person virginia
jury wouldn't only be tasked with
deciding if these statements were
defamatory but if any of them were what
would be the damages or payout
depp claimed he lost his career and
reputation due to the op-ed piece
after the op-ed it was
impossible to get him
a studio film which is what we normally
would have been focused on in that time
period prior to 2016 and the allegations
um
the abuse allegations uh mr depp was not
portrayed in a negative connotation
after the op-ed there seemed to be kind
of a theme or a flavor of
not only the abuse allegations but his
drinking and drug use
i concluded that
mr depp uh suffered lost earnings
of approximately 40 million dollars
amber heard claim though depp's own
actions not the 2018 op-ed led to the
downfall of his career
and how did it become
far more complicated in the last 10
years
his unprofessional behavior
showing up late to set
consistently
on virtually every movie and it made
people
reluctant to use him toward the end
likewise heard argued her life and
career trajectory were never the same
after the dep waldman statements
it can you point us to any career
opportunities that ms heard has lost
because of any statements made by mr
waldo
i mean that that the amazon movie for
one is one that i is tangible because
that
is an example of something that she had
before all of it that was then um taken
away how much would amber hurt have been
able to negotiate
her contract but for the deb waldman
statements she certainly could have
increased it by one or two million
dollars or even doubled it without any
of this
negativity that was created by the woman
the deb waldman statements
not only did depp respond with his own
expert criticizing herds
her assessment of damages
is built on
nothing and it's wildly speculative
but there was evidence that heard's
future such as in the aquaman series was
in jeopardy for other reasons as
outlined by warner brothers executive
walter hamada the issue of chemistry did
the two epic chemistry
um you know i think editorially they
were able to make that relationship work
in the first movie but there was a
concern that it took a lot of effort to
get there
and would we be better off
recasting finding someone who had better
more natural chemistry with pizza mama
eventually after weeks of testimony we
came towards the end of the trial depp
heard and their attorneys made their
final please to the jury
no human being is perfect certainly not
have never
in my life
committed
sexual battery
physical abuse
no matter what happens i did get here
and i did tell the truth
every single day i have to relive the
trauma
my hands shake i wake up screaming this
is horrible
this is painful
and this is humiliating for any human
being
to go through
the mountain of evidence that mr depp
abused misheard is simply not there
and you can't pick and choose which of
these wild allegations to believe and
which ones to disregard
you either believe all of it or none of
it
if you believe the depp was abusive to
amber one time ever in any of the
various forms of abuse
not only physical verbal emotional
psychological sexual any of the ways of
abuse
then your job is very easy
no woman ever before amber heard ever
claimed that mr depp raised a hand to
her in his 58 years
this is me too
without any me too
so we're fighting back and that's the
counter plane
she finally has said enough
enough
and we're asking you to finally
hold this man responsible
after nearly 13 hours of deliberations
with the world watching including over
3.5 million live viewers on the lawn
crime network's youtube page the jury
came back with their decision
quote i spoke up against sexual violence
and faced our culture's wrath
that has to change end quote
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer
yes two
quote then two years ago i became a
public figure
representing domestic abuse and i felt
the full force of our culture's wrath
for women who speak out end quote
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes
three quote i had the rare vantage point
of seeing in real time how institutions
protect men
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes
we the jury award compensatory damages
in the amount of 10 million dollars
we the jury award punitive damages in
the amount of 5 million
in the end amber heard was liable to
johnny depp for each one of her
statements in the op-ed the jury
ultimately deciding these were false
claims and were made with actual malice
as for her counter claims she won with
respect to only one statement wallman's
accusations of a staged scene
as against john c depp ii we the jury
award compensatory damages in the amount
of two million dollars
we the jury award punitive damages in
the amount of zero dollars
after the verdict johnny depp released a
statement saying in part quote the jury
gave me my life back i also hope that
the position will now return to innocent
until proven guilty both within the
courts and in the media
as for amber heard she released a
statement saying in part quote the
disappointment i feel today is beyond
words i'm even more disappointed with
what this verdict means for other women
it is a setback i seem to have lost a
right i thought i had as an american to
speak freely and openly
the last time that it got crazy between
us i really did think i was gonna lose
my life
i lost a
finger man come on
sees how many people believe or side
with you
no matter where you stand or how you
feel about this case there's no denying
that it had a tremendous impact and
despite the celebrity the salacious
details the drama this was a story about
real and serious issues of domestic
violence mental health and substance
abuse that affect so many people across
the country today and perhaps that's the
biggest takeaway over anything else
thanks for joining us here on prime
crime
until next time be safe
[Music]
you